when you start to think about mining
there seems to be a ton of conversation
around mining death spiral as there
always is in bear markets uh miners
selling their bitcoin that are publicly
traded uh how much of your focus is on
what i'll call it more institutionalized
or kind of commercial mining versus the
individual just buying like a single
machine and kind of plugging in at their
house or something like that
right so of course we're working as a
generalist fund in the bitcoin space so
we invest across the board and some of
the pain points for minors are similar
for companies of all types
and we're seeing one now which is
you know effectiveness of treasury
management and planning
finances and planning for various
scenarios and treasury management and so
miners of course have been primarily
funded by debt
and as a result of the debt markets
drying up we see miners needing to sell
into a down market selling bgc um but
this isn't something new right we've
seen this in prior cycles and so it's
just something that we need to get
through and of course it also when
companies have financial pressures it
opens up new opportunity spaces right so
we're looking to see if there'll be
acquisition activity if there'll be
opportunities for new entrepreneurs to
come in and to do things more
efficiently or effectively or to serve
clients whether those be enterprise or
institutional grade clients or retail
folks better and so that's sort of you
know where it's early right we're kind
of we're sort of early into this um
this you know more like chaotic dynamic
in the mining space controlled chaos
and so we're just looking to see how
that shakes out and if there's
opportunities for innovation there